so this is home and work with home
office
living room
kitchen everything you want to call it
we joined jimmy just before he hits the
road to austria tea coffee everything i
need he's been trucking for 40 years and
tells us he's not surprised there's a
driver shortage what's changed everyone
thought truckers were happy what's
happened well we've never really been
happy per se
we're in a job where like over christmas
we were we were the knights of the road
we were heroes you know um some
particular service stations i won't name
them actually gave us free coffees and a
sandwich or something like that but of
course since then it's all just gone
back to where it used to be which is no
respect for the lorry driver whatsoever
from pay to hours brexit to covid jimmy
says the driver crisis is a combination
of issues so here we are parked up for
the night
this is
the best i can do this evening
it's only
half past seven english time but
unfortunately all the truck stops are
full
good morning world
it's uh
almost quarter four quick cup of tea and
then one way to ashford and the train to
calais
for jimmy once he crosses the channel
driving an hgv
is a different ball game go to holland
you turn up a company the first words
you hear are you want a coffee
you haven't even opened your truck you
haven't handed a slice of paper in when
you arrive you are treated as a human
being they appreciate you are a driver
you are a professional you're doing a
job for them
this is a track stop
look at it it's just amazing
my breakfast has arrived fresh mushroom
omelette cup of coffee a little bit of
salad toast and butter what chance then
of the british government getting
european drivers back in the uk
these guys have found jobs in europe
in germany in austria where they're
respected and where they get good pay
why should they come back that's not
going to happen
your message
to the transport secretary and the
government what do they need to do
support the truck driver get behind the
truck driver
we need them and they need us but they
need us more than we need them
and the government needs them quickly if
this shortfall is to be filled by
christmas
dan whitehead sky news in southampton